idaho rejectos we gotta watch ourselves
some banana benign
what episode is this john it's two by
six that is season two
episode six
all we ask is that you hit that like
button you know you know
it's not hard it's not hard to just hit
that button you're probably watching
from your phone just poop little bump
right there it's happening just tap that
little tap the little button for us just
get a little tap little tip tip right
there and full length watch along our
patreon cover much shows everyday thanks
to pepper fritting these down for us
let's do it
[Music]
901 amy santiago is officially late for
the first time ever who's got theories
alarm didn't go off all three alarms all
with battery backup come on who wants to
take this seriously she was taken in her
sleep super dark boyle but way more
plausible than the sarge's idiotic alarm
clock
she fell into another dimension where
she's interesting it's 9 a.m
why is no one working amy santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why i like to play
i'd say she's in line at the
bank is fun
[Laughter]
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you dare to
explain yourself i'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
[Laughter]
dude
captain holt's getting into it with the
team nowadays yeah he's being influenced
man
he's a part of the fam
not to overstate it but i'm definitely
going to die alone and work is all i
have i take your dating's not going well
what
it's awesome what happened with rose's
been katie yeah she turned out to be
even more closed off than rosa so how
long have you known rosa none of your
business
all right
don't talk about being a cop just
talk about my own interests exactly hey
she's cute
and alone
oh
eva longoria oh guest star
you should run
going to meetings writing stuff down you
love that nerd stuff writing things down
is nerdy what do you do i just forget
stuff like a cool person
so cool
it's nothing amateur night i can't
believe this had three peppers next to
it on the menu oh my god oh oh how hot
lojos might be drink the ranch drink the
rice
[Laughter]
the luxury sex romp we had planned this
weekend the hotel says the bubbles and
bathrobes package is non-refundable see
that's why i didn't want to pre-paid
charles yeah but that's why we got such
a good deal one hour free wi-fi
[Music]
okay if one of us is getting pampered
all night it's gonna be me i want that
room gina you can't push me around we're
not poke pals anymore ew
hmm boy i'll probably pay for it yeah he
probably did you're running against me
what rosa must have done this i'll get
her to stop you know what really burns
my pants
i considered you my best friend
guess what happened last night spoiler
alert sexy times okay now guess sexy
time yes the whole night was amazing we
totally hit it off i found our meatloaf
wings the band of the show the food
[Laughter]
did some adult stuff and spent the rest
of the night debating who was the better
ping-pong player she was adorably wrong
oh my gosh she's still working at the
court oh no
hey you're absolutely right so we have a
little delay gary the defense attorney
isn't going to be here oh guess who it's
going to be
gary broke his leg so he's being
replaced so who's the new sub-human
piece of human garbage sophia perez
oh
god
you slept with a defense attorney
you literally slept with the enemy i
know
ah it's like if john mcclane slept with
hans gruber or even worse jeremy irons
from the third one
here behind you what about william
sadler from the second one
hey
all right i'm gonna go talk to her
be strong
be strong
you never told me you were a cop yeah
you never told me you were a lawyer well
i didn't want to intimidate you
intimidate wow okay well not to burst
your bubble but i'm only intimidated by
professions that have a moral compass
like police officer
look at me i'm a lawyer i'm so good at
word using gatud and yes i know that
that wasn't a word right okay you know
what
this is clearly a conflict of interest
so i'm just gonna talk to the judge and
have you kicked off the case
no there's no conflict of interest
because i'm not interested in you
god i can't believe i slept with a cop
it's like i had sex with hans gruber
as i told you i'm not allowed to get
involved it's too late anyway you
already have a campaign slogan picking
me dummies
please tell her i shouldn't run for
union right saying i should just return
this button maker you think you can
tempt me with the t-150 button maker sir
you've got to see this it doesn't even
make mirror backs
this is a joke
full disclosure your honor last night ms
perez and i got inebriated and we had
colitis colitis poitus
no
you think i might tell everybody in the
courtroom that you like to be the little
spoon everyone likes to be the little
spoon it makes you feel safe carl back
me up on this yes little spoon all the
way
i can be mature says the guy who uses a
sunglasses case as a wallet stuff can be
two things open up your refrigerator
boom air conditioner life hacked carl
back me up i mean it's not very green
the room is mine you scab no it's mine
gina i'm not backing down this time
i'm backing up
[Music]
[Laughter]
every time she looks over i'm gonna hit
her with one of these
it'll remind her that we kissed and
that's how i get in her head you want me
to flex and make all the buttons pop off
my shirt you can do that the challenge
is keeping the buttons on
okay okay okay okay i want to see that
your case is a mess
kind of like your ping-pong
oh my god she smells so good come on
terry let's go save the day carl you
want to come no thank you all right
[Laughter]
also your posture seems off like it's
good because i'm being serious because i
don't want this perk to walk this isn't
about the perp
oh no it's about this woman
jake slept with her oh she's so pretty
she looks like the woman on an olive oil
bottle way to go jake she's a defense
attorney
[Laughter]
well here was the perps house built in
some of those old brownstones had dumb
waiters a perfect hiding spot i'm gonna
win this case and then we can put my
horrible sexual experience behind us
forever i don't know jake i'm afraid i'm
gonna think about it every time i look
at your crotch then stop looking at my
crush
what are you doing
just pointing people to the one
detective who actually wants to run for
union rep best leaders don't want the
job
i want to be captain one day and
clashing with the brass is career
suicide not for me
by my very nature i was constantly in
conflict with my superiors listen you're
black and
oh god i strongly disagree
run for union rep amy okay
i'll do it never tell anyone about this
pow-wow you called it a bow
including a glass cutter he used to
break into the store yes but isn't it
possible my client could have used the
glass cutter for something other than a
robbery stuff can do two things right
hey i say that that's my saying your
honor she stole my saying
in fact i believe it was the great john
adams who once said to believe all men
honest is folly
to believe none is something worse
let the record show ms perez looks
stunned and defeated no further question
[Laughter]
we the jury find the defendant
not guilty no come on
oh
oh i'm in too much pain to care how cool
and strong that made me look it was
already splintering don't take this away
from me
i wonder if that was supposed to happen
i hate defense attorneys as much as any
rational adult but you obviously have
feelings for sophia yeah anger i don't
know it just seems to me like you met
your match
all right fine she's super hot god i
can't believe i'm about to ask out a
defense attorney
amy santiago wants to be captain one day
which means she will never stand up to
management i don't want to be captain i
just want my party stuff
he also said if you voted for him you'd
get a golden boat
that's not real
[Laughter]
most importantly i'll bring back party
sub leftovers
[Applause]
pick amy dummies
[Applause]
look if we're gonna do this we're gonna
have to have a couple rules rule number
one starting right now no work talk
perfect we can just skip straight to
making out on your desk
no i don't like that nope yeah that's
not my desk this is
copy that
blame it on the janitor and make a break
for it absolutely after you
good staging
i too am disappointed by this
unfortunate stalemate why are you
talking all victorian you're lying about
something that's what that means
nonsense milady
i gave the hotel room to my father and
told him to check in under my name what
no
i gave my key to my mom
oh no
i'm sorry i must have the wrong room
that's okay
steven root and regina's been
encouraging me to have some
romantic adventures
holy cow no
oh we're definitely gonna see those
characters again sometime
she's the lady from roseanne who we
found out was gay who was once married
to tom arnold on the show oh
tom arnold
dude and he
is on never been
nope never once not a thing
well
i have a solid prediction
what's your predict what do you think
it's gonna be that eva longoria is going
to be a recurring character
nay nay oh but you're not wrong plot
twist
ah it's not going to work out
between them
because she's going to just be a
recurring character
and tells me it's not going to work out
that's a good prediction if you can't
talk about your jobs at all
come on that that won't work especially
when their
their lives revolve around their jobs
they're gonna need a little event too
and to discuss the nitty-gritty with
it's like olivia and i talking about all
the hardships
working with children
having to endure
taking care of
the youth's lives
[Music]
discipline
mentor
and then i go in and go
this video won't go public on youtube
for some reason
this is a bunch of [ __ ] why do i
suffer and slave
she's there for me and i'm like yeah
yeah olivia
i know a kid peed on you today but this
this mobius video she's just morpheus
trailers not monetized i just can't deal
i got a copyright
[Laughter]
on one of the three videos i posted
today
yeah it's some harsh times here but if
we couldn't talk about it
you couldn't get it out you know and if
she couldn't listen to me while i let
her just quickly get her stuff out and
well i before you interrupt interrupt
and divulge for extensive periods of
time
hours some days most days even then we
wouldn't work out man
i know it's been mostly something
special it's not gonna work it comes
into conflict
it's like
you can't have a
alt-right data far left and just agree
never to talk to you it's not gonna work
it's gonna seep through regardless it'll
come through in other ways man
point of views yeah subconscious man but
damn are they gonna have a banging good
time absolutely because that difference
in perspectives and that competitiveness
leads to
toxic relationships that they mistake
for passion
yeah man all passionate relationships
involve intense fighting
otherwise that's the reverse of loving
passion
angry furious passion
that's not gonna work out
and uh
what does a union person do
uh i mean you fight for the rights of
the people
working you know the workers basically
writes and stuff like that so he gives
his [ __ ]
uh you know
no one really
they put their lives on unions benefit
no one can't think of a single union
that's ever done a good thing for
somebody
wasn't the in this hollywood industry
just protesting for a union because they
wanted to shut the union down because
they do too much good for them yeah
they want to unionize union workers to
get
worse benefits from the unions they get
treated too
they're too privileged right it's from
my understanding yeah they're giving us
too much so we need to unionize and keep
them in line and make sure that we don't
get greedy over here my man that's the
kind of union i'm going to start would
you like to join you can be the
president
no i like benefits but thank you uh yeah
you know
you
you're not down for the cause chomp what
are you gonna benefit off of all the
[ __ ] that we do for you all the health
benefits that
i provide here at the real rejects yes
my 401k
oh no your hmo insurance
my dental plan
my vision plan
my uh life insurance
fund yeah man it's all gonna go away if
we unionize oh come on man you just got
to get a um
what's that package called an nra what
is that called
oh oh oh um i got one
i signed an nda recently no same thing
you put like a few thousand into it an
ira ira
you gotta get an ira man oh you gotta
learn to invest your money
uh okay do you invest
um
that's enough i've invested i have i've
invested in a couple of things but i i
need to continue but now i owe them
money
well i mean
i mean one thing was more because i was
like oh yes i have an active interest in
investing in this thing although it's
not necessarily one where i'm like i'm
investing in this cause it's gonna turn
a profit so that's the kind of investing
i need to learn
and i should guess what do you think i
was talking about
just giving my money to the homeless
it's like anyone who asks out on the
street that's an investment right i
could write that off it's like
charitable donations right you got to
learn to make your earnings grow yeah
we're also going to slave away forever
should i get an ira how many thousands
of dollars should i put in my forty
thousand dollars a thousand dollars into
my ira all right no it's i forget how
much but you could put like um a certain
minute maximum every year
but it it accumulates anyway before
i don't know what we're talking about
this one i'm just gonna take a note of
that really you can do it online look
into an ira right here you do it online
um yeah so
guys get an ira if you're self-employed
or you make your living off commission
thank you local union for whatever it
does to help you out
and uh what else is there to happen in
this episode andre brauer great again
gina and boyle dude are they gonna
keep not hook it up
uh they're gonna keep maybe not hooking
up but their their parents are gonna
hook the fudge up that is so
uncomfortable i know but probably a real
life saver for the two of them instant
icebreaker intimate setting pedals on
the battles that's like your mom and
jayden smith's dad hooking up yes
disturbing yes
that is
yeah i don't i don't know what i would
do if i found out about that you know i
might go vomit and then uh you know
become very starstruck you know what
happened if you walked in
oh my god mom what are you doing and
then you just hear the sound of
[Laughter]
big willy
big billy style yeah getting jiggy with
it
no no no no no no
yeah it's funny it's it's the first time
i've ever imagined what uh
what uh will smith might sound like uh
mid colitis
coitus apologies
call back call back
it's funny right we called back the
unions
called back colitis
now we just need one more to get to the
rule of threes
which is a comedic tenet
guys let me explain comedy to you really
fast cause once i do
this whole video is gonna bust your [ __ ]
uh yeah and then amy santiago running
for the union round we already covered
that by her she's perfect she's perfect
he's gonna bring scully's a sandwich and
then the parents doing it parents are
doing it everyone's good holt's good
all right yeah we're done we did it we
covered the whole funny ass episode tell
us your thoughts on what you liked about
the episode remember to like and
subscribe comment go over to patreon
watch the full thing whatever you want
to do is eva longoria
done anything outside of desperate
housewives
like
a movie
yeah she's doing like a movie has she
been in a movie
i mean she probably has like a thick
imdb and i can't conjure a single movie
to my i know she's done some movies
she's very ugly
well it's the ugly actresses yeah just
like unfortunate monstrosities today
that we've been seeing just like harsh
to look at people yeah really stings the
eyes yes it makes me want to physically
close them and just like make sure no
light enters for fear that i might have
to look upon her once more
anyway hey let's do it
jordan
jordan i see that you pledge towards the
end of october and now you're here
segwaying into november and you're
probably asking yourself
was i ought to renew charge without me
realizing
i
hope that's not the case that we can
discuss further
um
listen
i am not going to show your profile pic
here on camera because i once got in
trouble for doing that without person's
permission but i will instead describe
my emotions associated with seeing your
photo
i have two
one is
is this a head shot because it looks
good
the other is
is this person gonna kick my ass
because he looks like he could kick my
ass
you have an intimidating
sexual alluring presence about yourself
i don't mean that in a harassment kind
of way that's the way you disclaim you
make a disclaimer for anything you say
that could be provocative or
sexually harassing in nature
so you have
a very horny alluring look about
yourself that i don't quite see in a lot
of people just based off their profile
pics here at our patreon so i gotta say
you are seducing me
wildly and i hope that by the time you
reel me in you also follow through with
kicking my ass and auditioning
for my next short film that i'm doing
called demons hill
it's about uncovering many hidden bodies
lurking about the santa monica mountains
this is fascinating i really hope that
jordan decides to star in the movie
jordan only after kicking your ass and
having sex with you i had to do two
times a shout out for two times to
pledge
jordan yeah that's what you get
but don't don't come my way because much
like eva longoria i i think you're just
vomitingly hideous so you and greg can
have fun
whoa you gotta clarify your being sorry
i am being sarcastic something to make
it where's the red light about eva
longoria
where's our sarcasm about jordan jordan
i was trying to make a call back joke
and what a call back joke is let me
explain some more comedy
[Music]